wading through flood water is the only
way adam ismail and his mother can get
to their home flood waters wrecked the
property in sudan's jazeera state and
their family was forced to seek drier
lands
we woke up to water entering the homes
and got out what we could
every hour there is a house that's
fallen or a sewage system that's
collapsed or a wall that's come down
there is nothing left
all the other homes in the village were
also flooded when heavy rains hit the
state two weeks ago
rains and torrential floods in sudan
have killed at least a hundred people
and hundreds others have been injured
tens of thousands of homes have been
destroyed hamdantia put up barricades
but his house still suffered major
damage
well how has it happened
we took out the children and what
furniture we could but the house had
been destroyed we built barriers and are
still draining out the water
now we're worried about the diseases the
water can bring like malaria as well as
other infections
the rainy season has been described by
some as one of the worst they've ever
seen and the downpours have affected
nearly the whole country jazira is one
of the states where the government has
declared a disaster dozens of villages
have been submerged here since the
beginning of the rainy season leaving
hundreds of families homeless
many have sought refuge on dryer lands
but they say they're yet to receive any
help
we practically need everything because
people lost everything shelter food
water healthcare the most important
thing we need is for the water to be
drained so they can go back i hear
people crying at night because of the
situation we are in
adam says he wants the waters to recede
so he and his mother could go back and
rebuild their home again
but after waiting for two weeks now he's
no idea when that might happen
hiba morgan al jazeera what the name
jazeera state